LIE TO ME."
AVAILABLE IN BOOKSTORES
EVERYWHERE.
JOINING ME BY PHONE, ERIC TRUMP
WITH THE LATEST ON HIS DAD’S
CONDITION.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, JUDGE.
JUDGE JEANINE: I KNOW OBVIOUSLY
IT’S YOUR DAD, YOU LOVE HIM AND
IT’S HIGHLY PERSONAL.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE SPOKEN TO
HIM TODAY AT LENGTH.
>> I DID.
HE’S A MAN I LOVE AND RESPECT.
HE’S A WARRIOR.
I THINK EVERYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS SEEN THAT.
HE’S AN ABSOLUTE WARRIOR EVERY
DAY.
WHETHER IT’S THIS OR ANYTHING
ELSE, HE GETS UP AND FIGHTS HE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
OBVIOUSLY COVID IS VERY, VERY
SERIOUS AND SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTED A LOT OF PEOPLE, AND
SOMETHING THAT HIT HIM VERY HARD
IN THE OPENING DAYS.
BUT I PROBABLY SPENT 20-25
MINUTES ON THE PHONE WITH HIM
TODAY.
HE SOUNDED GREAT.
THE ENTIRE TIME HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE NEW AID PACKAGE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT MITCH
MCCONNELL AND THE STIMULUS.
HE MENTIONED THE AIRLINE WORKERS
AND THINGS HE WANTED TO DO FOR
THEM.
HE NEVER TAKES HIS FOOT OFF THE
GAS.
HE MAY BE AT WALTER REED, BUT I
CAN ASSURE YOU HE WAS RUNNING A
THOUSAND MILES A MINUTE.
THE GO IS ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
HE’S THE ENERGIZER BUNNY.
NOTHING TAKES HIM DOWN.
AS SERIOUS AS COVID IS, AND AS
SCARY AS ME AS HIS SON TO WATCH
EVERYBODY.
I -- TO WATCH EVERYTHING.
WATCHING MARINE ONE TAKE OFF TO
GO TO WALTER REED IS A MEMORY I
DON’T FORGET.
I LOVE HIM TO DEATH.
HE SOUNDS GREAT.
HE WAS FULL OF ENERGY.
I THINK HE’S GOING TO BE A QUICK
RECOVERY.
HE WILL START FIGHTING AGAIN.
AND WE’LL KEEP WINNING FOR
AMERICA AND WE’LL WIN ON
NOVEMBER 3.
JUDGE JEANINE: ERIC, I WANT YOU
TO TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS SOUND
AND GET YOUR REACTION TO IT ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT I’M STARTING TO FEEL
GOOD.
YOU DON’T KNOW OVER THE NEXT
PERIOD OF A FEW DAYS, I GUESS
THAT’S THE REAL TEST.
WE’LL BE SEEING WHAT HAPPENS THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU KNOW, ERIC,
IT IS YOUR DAD, AND TO HEAR HIM
SAY YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
DAYS, HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU
FEEL.
>> IT DOESN’T MAKE YOU FEEL
GREAT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I HEARD THE
ENERGY AND THE VIGOR IN HIS
VOICE.
HE WAS AGAIN CREDIBLE AS I SAID
BEFORE.
THIS IS A DEADLY VIRUS.
HE WAS THE FIRST PERSON TO SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL TO CHINA.
I THINK MY FATHER IS GOING TO
HOLD CHINA FULLY ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT THAT’S FOR A LATER DATE.
TRAVEL, WHAT THEY HAVE DONE WITH
THE VACCINE, THE THERAPEUTICS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
NO ONE COULD HAVE DONE IT FASTER
THAN HE DID.
AND NOW HE’S BATTLING SOMETHING
THAT AFFECTED SO MANY AMERICANS
AND SO MANY PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND HE’S GOING TO BITE, AND WE
ARE GOING TO BEAT THE VIRUS.
I SEE VIDEOS ALL DAY ON FOX OF
THE INCREDIBLE SUPPORTERS
OUTSIDE WALTER REED HOLDING
AMERICAN FLAGS AND HOLDING THE
MAKE AMERICA GREAT FLAGS.
THE OUTCRY OF SUPPORT FOR HIM IS
INCREDIBLE.
WE LIVE IN A NATION THAT
ABSOLUTELY LOVES HIM.
YOU SEE THAT AT THE RALLIES
WHERE THEY ARE CHANTING "WE LOVE
YOU."
A COUPLE YEARS AGO IT WAS "BUILD
THE WALL" AND A LOT OF RED MEAT
STUFF.
NOW THEY ARE CHANTING "WE LOVE
YOU."
AS A SON, I COULDN’T BE MORE
PROUD OF THE MAN.
WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT AND KEEP
WINNING FOR THIS GREAT NATION WE
ALL LOVE SO MUCH.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHEN WE SAW HIM
TODAY IN THAT VIDEO THAT HE PUT
OUT THIS AFTERNOON, I THINK
EVERYONE HAS THE SENSE IF HE WAS
IN WALTER REED, IT’S A HOSPITAL
AND HE’S PROBABLY GOING TO BE IN
A ROBE.
BUFF HE’S IN A SUIT JACKET AND
SHIRT.
AND HIS HAIR IS COMBED.
HE TAKES INCOMING EVERY DAY.
BUT TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF WALTER
REED HONKING THEIR HORNS,
YELLING, TELLING HIM THEY LOVE
HIM.
I SEE IT WHEN I GO AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
BUT IT’S A WONDERFUL THING FOR
HIM TO TAKE IN THE LOVE AND
PRAYERS PEOPLE HAVE FOR HIM.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS SOMETHING HE
CAN CARRY WITH HIM TO FIGHT OFF
THE HATE THAT COMES FROM THE
LEFT.
AND I WILL TALK ABOUT THAT IN A
FEW MINUTES ON THE SHOW.
ANY LAST THOUGHTS?
>> THERE IS TREMENDOUS HATE FROM
THE LEFT.
EVEN IN A TIME LIKE THIS THAT
SHOULDSHOULD BE A SOMBER MOMENT.
BUT THERE IS ALSO TREMENDOUS
LOVE.
BUT HE’S DONE A GREAT JOB FOR
THIS NATION.
HE WAKES UP EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
GOES TO WAR FOR THIS NATION
PERSONALLY.
THERE HAS PROBABLY NEVER BEEN A
PRESIDENT WHO SACRIFICED MORE
THAN HE HAS.
I COULDN’T BE MORE PROUD OF HIM.
THE GUY IS AN INSPIRATION TO ME
AS A SON AND TO SO MANY OTHERS.
HE WILL GET THREW THIS.
EVERYBODY IS PRAYING FOR HIM.
HE SOUNDS GREAT.
AND HE’S MAKING AMERICA GREAT.
THAT’S WHAT ALL OF US WANT.
STANDS UP FOR RED, WHITE AND
BLUE, AND NEVER APOLOGIZES FOR
AMERICA.
JUDGE JEANINE: ERIC TRUMP, THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US TONIGHT,